here are some jokes that were popular in
1906. this Wireless telegraphy reminds
me of a groundless quarrel what possible
connection is there between the two it's
practically having words over nothing
I had soup in a restaurant the other day
and found an oyster in it
Great Scott that one oyster in the soup
joke is old yes but this was tomato soup
he kissed her on the cheek it seemed a
harmless Frolic he's been laid up a week
they say with painters colic
a man stole a harness the other day and
didn't leave a Trace
have you been cured of that last attack
of malaria oh yes
Dr Anna kurum knocked it silly but her
treatment left me with a worse disease
than malaria ever was you don't say yes
sir I've got incurable heart disease now